people living on these islands off the
coast of the mainland are watching
events unfold in ukraine as chinese
warplanes carry out incursions into
taiwan's air defense zone
64 year old linda's show has always
lived with the threat that china might
seize dongjian island by force
if they provoke us we still can't touch
them if they want to fly over the island
just let them fly if you shoot them down
everything will be over i'm not kidding
you it would be the start of the third
world war it's really too scary it
wouldn't even just be us and the
mainland fighting other countries would
surely also join in the fight just look
at the war between russia and ukraine if
they use atomic bombs it'll all be over
no country would be able to escape
dongjin is only 50 kilometers off the
mainland
the island is home to a missile base and
military drills are held regularly to
prepare for potential assault by chinese
forces
first of all it needs to be pointed out
that taiwan is not ukraine the taiwan
question and the ukraine issue are
different in nature fundamentally taiwan
is an inalienable part of china's
territory the taiwan question is purely
china's internal affairs and there can
be no foreign interference the two sides
across the taiwan strait must be and
will be reunified it is the trend of
history that can never be stopped by
anyone or any force
for younger people that's now easier to
imagine
i don't think the threat of the war has
a big influence on our daily lives but
of course it will come up in everyone's
conversations but we will discuss it in
a rather light-hearted manner for
example when we explore strongholds we
would discuss if a war really starts
which nearby stronghold we would run to
because recently there's been discussion
about bomb shelters in taiwan about
where to go to take shelter and so on
but life goes on as usual here and
people hope that isn't about to change
andrew chappelle al jazeera